louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the plate
[Music]
ah thanks to a funding from mclubbe
those false plaintiffs have pulled their
hard strikes again right on time
to the second they always do I fight
them for you and we win every time and
you always act like it's a miracle
oh my dear half-asian tattoo when each
mug club member is paying $99 annually
69 for students veterans our active
military he/she or Z deserves miracles
all right both that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I just wanted you to think of you're
watching this in the archive that you
were too hammered to watch this show but
it's actually moving around that way we
have Senator Rand Paul on the show today
remember to be a question of the day
what was your main takeaway from
Wednesday's hearing on bar the highlight
if you will gonna be talking about that
Venezuela and usually introduce him last
rightfully so but he is back gee Morgan
a married man I will say I was official
I can confirm I was at the wedding okay
I was very surprised she was actually
just a cardboard cutout of Jack LaLanne
yes the one so apparently when I was
gone there was a bit of a thing about
boxed wines baby there we go so funny
well know a guy I would go and shut I
would go shopping and I'd be like I'd go
on Twitter saying well since I'm for
looking for Gerald the wine of the day
is show you I picked this cheap right of
this to do cheese is there good box wine
is there anything yeah there's plenty of
I mean for people who just want everyday
wines would you marry but even who likes
box wine I did she likes great wine now
- um okay I'm exposing her to a lot of
great wines that she's really enjoying
oh okay quarterblack geared of course in
there now sir how you doing I'm doing
great are you good at words we're doing
well in doubt leading the news before
sir good wines to do went to France yeah
of course you had to have the gentleman
cutout laminated single-handedly keeps
Amazon's nano cloth storefront and
business that's right baby leading those
things are remarkable times a million
yeah it's just leading the news of
course you know attorney and we're going
into Venezuela that's the most we have
to talk about bar because we have to
Venezuela thing is we have a job
so William bar he didn't attend the
House Judiciary hearing today for
Thursday those who are listening to the
archive now the main reason was a
dispute over who'd be doing the
questioning and he felt that he left it
all on stage yesterday and since we
already analyzed it yesterday from mug
Club members and the Ash Wednesday and
you're probably
tired of hearing about it we're just
well that brings us to a bill Bars def
Comedy Jam
[Music]
all right so if you like expect an
analysis yeah yeah we ain't got it
because it's for people who missed it
from for bill bar uh let's go to our
greatest hit
senator Blumenthal clip war did anyone
either you or anyone on your staff
memorialize your conversation with
robert muller yes
who did that there were notes taken of
the call may we have those notes no
[Applause]
who had the power to make the decision
about whether or not the evidence was
sufficient project make a determination
of whether there had been an obstruction
of justice
prosecution memos go up to the
supervisor in this case it was the
attack you know the Attorney General and
the Deputy Attorney General who decide
on the final decision and that is based
on the memo as presented by the US
Attorney's Office I just want to nail
down
you used the word spying hmm about
authorized DOJ investigative activities
frankly we went back and looked at press
usage and up until all the the for
outrage a couple of weeks ago it's
commonly used in the press to refer to
authorized activities such as reference
and I sorta use my department what it is
not commonly used by the department my
time is commonly used by me
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I'm not gonna lie on a little VIN
dude oh man a person of color is exhaust
it's difficult yes oh man that was good
everything is so bright now okay so for
just just so now he's just Brautigan is
just make all the noise like you want to
roughest talked about this yesterday
this is just we don't want to ride a
full-on analysis everyone's been doing
it but yesterday I said watch you're
going to see tomorrow the clips are
going to be Kamala Harris and her oh no
everyone's going to be saying this is
the ownage this is a sound bite but none
of it is true that not matters I think
we have harris or just her oh no her oh
no okay this is the one I want to show
you that the left has been showing as
their big victory lap for context here's
her own Owen questioning do you think
all of the things that President Trump
did are okay you think it's okay for the
president we go to investigation was
about illegality and I don't think the
evidence supports about the Ansari do
you think it's okay for a president to
ask his White House Counsel to lie which
do you think it's okay for a president
jaw for pardons to people who don't
testify against him what you threatened
the family what are you talking about
does is that okay
when did he offer a pardon to say I
think you know what I'm talking about
internal you know give us some credit
for knowing what the hell is going on
around here with you I give you no can
you give me any specifics okay start
with the games hold on a second is it
knows that a racial stereotype possibly
and then come all the Harris asked a
question she asked should did the white
hat did Donald Trump or the White House
ask
you to investigate anybody what someone
extra to succinct and pointed questions
of Kamala Harris it could not be less
Funyuns and the Dems just won't let go
of this like she obviously has been
caught right there you give us some
credit for know what we're talking about
no no you get no credit this is a losing
strategy for you guys how do you think
this is a win to keep getting owned like
this on national college I saw on The
Young Turks they were talking about this
and they said uh we agree with the
report that maybe there's no collusion
but there could have been obstruction
that's how can it be obstruction and
they're arguing now whose business ties
with Russia hold on a second wait a
second that's not what you called an
investigation for you know that's not
that kind of precedent where someone
pulls you over for a broken taillight oh
wait you're till it's not broken
I haven't oughta bring you into the shop
because I think maybe you hit your kid
do any proof no you know you call for
investigation it's been done he's not
well no let's go to visit they never
want to stop that's the point that's why
I don't want to analyze it he is the
smartest guy in the room though and I
did enjoy watching it here's your other
huh take out the wake up Cory Yahoo Game
of Thrones that keep killing off the
entire immigrant population oh that's a
problem they're not wrong if they killed
off the show that'd be okay where once
it seemed like the show had something to
say about the topic of immigration I'm
no longer sure it's interested in such
heady ideas anymore
Yahoo spoiler alert you're gonna hate
episode six
yeah that's not goes on this it makes a
really good point maybe that there was a
wall for a reason they didn't understand
the threat on the other side of the law
I'm like ah that's like real life right
now wasn't it to keep the gingers
because it's a recessive gene retain
your I don't want to have that I'm
actually curious what waka taco would
taste like they would stay away from the
spice I don't think it'd show like that
is supposed to be talking about those
ideas anyway they weren't making any
kind of showing this has gotten way too
analytical for something that was meant
to be super
by the people listening to people
listening an audio we get even just just
watch it in international news anyway a
club is now teaching young boys how to
be alpha males in order to fight k-pops
influence in China comes from the LA
kang hyeyeon founded the real man
training club to combat china's
masculinity crisis part of the backlash
against the makeup and earring wearing
male TV film and paper
leave it to China and hyeon's methods
are actually being called controversial
particularly given his policy of hunting
down and executing the entire cast of
Glee
so that seam shop was so close what the
crying kid from Glee we had to zoom in
to me the funniest thing about that
picture actually goes back to the pitch
room where you were like what about the
gay guy from Glee you need to be more
specific
right yeah it's kind of everybody from
Glee yeah one of the guys was actually
quoting he said twenty percent of the
people were a men were unfit for
military service anyway not to list like
things that matter you know like they
get and run they were out of shape
they're watching too many YouTube videos
and they pay too much it's like well I'm
sorry well why is that the thing that
ends up on the like do you think it's
good to and the funny thing is we're
supposed to be concerned that China is
gonna take over the world
yeah watching videos a lot well if
they're getting rid of them that must
mean it's the exception so they have a
lot of time on their hands speaking of
which movie in his new memoir he says
that he was drinking heavily to process
his grief over 9/11 and he claims that
he rubbed his doneger on President
Donald Trump as cons from Daily Beast he
said I drank a shot of vodka to brace
myself pulled my flaccid d-word out of
my pants and casually walked past Trump
trying to brush the edge of his jacket
with my wiener luckily he didn't seem to
notice and actually we uncovered
exclusive audio Oh from the concert in
question oh wow
[Music]
whoa bye Oh gross
copyright from Moby yeah the funny thing
is he's talking about like each drinking
he's doing drugs he's having sex and
tetanus II bathroom so he's doing all of
these things and then sets the tunnel
Trump is the bad person in the story
you're out doing all these things and
Trump's the bad guys Grossman and you
rubbed your penis on it why because he
cut aids funding right yeah you're doing
illegal drugs sleeping with random
people a drunk for three months and you
suck oh the only thing my son worked
with Moby on the French Canyon
definitely creatio was he came in and
she was he was a jerk back then yeah I
just find it funny that this is the
first time you've heard mobis name since
like he got this by Eminem in the
district right and he still is the one
who looks like a douche in the situation
right pretty much which not only is that
sexually sexual assault but honestly I
don't really know how it's an insult to
the person yeah who is on will he's the
only unwilling participant you rubbed
your penis on another man and not that
man that's embarrassing for you yet for
him and that's something you would like
do an elementary school or something
like that like where did you go to grade
school apparently a lot tougher place
than you did you got a penis rubbed on
you was on you you know kindig all that
touch you know he was Neverland Academy
where your teachers the Village People
what school did you go to no but if you
did something started like punched did
you ever once have somebody rubbed their
schmeckel on you no no but I think
kindergarten is his code word for
honeymoon yes that's fair I had somebody
try it like you put like if you had your
hand on your hip in the locker room or
something like that somebody would come
up and like do it it'd be funny to their
friends you know what I mean like they
try to touch you and you're like get
away from me you'll remember stuff like
that no no Oxford professor now is
arguing that invisible and cut out
objectively are interbreeding with
humans this comes from this important
box student dr. young hey Qi case we
didn't have all the Asians mad at us it
is in his fifty five minute presentation
he said it in abduct
shouldn't researcher in the US who
argued that aliens primary purpose is to
colonize the earth by interbreeding with
humans to produce a new hybrid species
second-generation hybrids are according
to Jacobs walking unobserved among us he
also went on to note that he is single
of course
some suspect ulterior motives given his
recent launch of invisible aliens to
have sex with match.com which
unfortunately for him most of all proved
to be unfruitful
[Laughter]
I just don't think he's my type long
walks on the beach could you be original
I just have one request if there's that
if there's an Alf come back it's because
of this show I hope so yeah there wasn't
there I thought there was if there's a
second I'll come back better than it was
everyone looking back with rose-colored
glasses on that she'll look back it is
just it is paint by paint-by-numbers
that that don't even line up this has
three digits goes up to six that's how
bad Alf is yeah is this the kind of
story though that you do the kind of
article that you write that gets you
punted from all kinds of academia like
you're never allowed back Jim be wanted
for it right the Chevy because no no eww
misunderstand he actually studied the
relation between interdimensional
invisible aliens hybridizing with humans
in relation to climate change yes make
sense all right the winner of last
week's trivia contest is Andrew Morales
I'm DJ am around food who knew that
Brautigan dressed up as spider-man was
ineligible
isn't Morales isn't that the spider-man
in the cartoons miles miles okay just a
Latino name all right brings us to the
top five lessons learned from Venezuela
let me ask you this what have you
learned most from the story unfolding in
Venezuela everyone's been talking about
bar this has been a little lost in the
shuffle yeah nothing surprising no right
yeah they've really taught us a lot so
obviously they've reached a boiling
point right the citizens been staging
massive demonstrations against the
dictator Matt Maduro and pyla how do you
pronounce the name of the legitimate
president oh gosh I don't know well I
know
is it is it sure I'll just say one last
thing was very hard for me to watch
properly one president want good Godot
good Gaudi got a good day I don't know
but anyway they've been there have been
demonstrations going on obviously
against dictator material yes not
recognized so there's so one the other
guy recognized as the interim president
by both the United States this is
important to note and other nations
actually I think we have a clip and a
freeze here in Scituate we just we can't
show it because they've been running
over dissidents with tanks and Maduro is
for people who have been felt let me
give you a brief kind of history lesson
he's a socialist turned dictator but I
repeat myself better yes civilians and
this is this is what's so important so
well ha no this is an example of pure
socialism ok the most tragic thing here
is that it is entirely predictable this
is the first time this kind of a
government has running over with tanks
no it happens all the time
armored personnel carriers in that stage
but it doesn't matter they ran them over
and I just gonna say like the most
disturbing thing is like what's going on
actually going on to Venezuela now is
the stuff that we say sarcastically to
socialists in this country yeah that is
gonna turn into right yeah exactly and
before you say that it's not true
socialism let me walk you through the
top lessons we've learned to why it is
lesson number five by the way is that
democratic socialists are gonna hate
lessons for through one and the marks a
page join up at Mudd Club by the way
because we're it and everything's do
monetized in iTunes so the fourth lesson
that I think is most important is that
socialism doesn't work and I know
there's a lot of people say well this is
it no no halt second we're not talking
about about places like Venezuela
actually do you know how I know you
Bernie Sanders and celebrities have long
praised Venezuela and other South
American socialist countries what they
did it when their economies seemed to
work way back in what was the 1961 they
invaded Cuba and everybody was totally
convinced the Castro was the worst guy
in the world all the Cuban people will
be absolutely a billion against Fidel
Castro
they'd forgot that he educated the kids
gave them health care totally
transformed twenty sometimes
journalists talk about how better the
country is because people are lining up
for food that's a good thing
the other countries people don't line up
Oh
his view is skewed because there's no
line up in the prune juice aisle by the
way argue that it's not real so do you
know how I know that it's not true still
today okay Bernie still has an article
on his website today right now that
claims Venezuelans are living the
American dream better than the United
States today now right now right now and
I guarantee you after this show they
probably wait two weeks until this blows
over and then remove it and then you can
time machine go back to today right now
this Thursday what's the date May
sectors they're May second second still
says on Bernie Sanders website official
website that Venezuelans are living the
American dream is that lining up for a
toilet paper and having to eat dogs
because you're starving to death I don't
remember that being the American you
cannot you cannot simply say it's not
real socialism because it doesn't work
now you praised it Bernie still praises
it this is what you wanted it's what you
got it's over you're done screw your
attempted pivot to Denmark they don't
want you
the irony of all ironies here is that
that Bernie Sanders is setting up that
capitalists are the worst people right
rich capitalists are the people that you
have to hate they're the ones that has
taken I don't know not that you have to
hate or the worst people but he does
vilify them more than Allah scum he does
yes give the benefit of the doubt there
the zoomit altruism yes - so their lives
villain in the story right and he's
supposed to be the heroine coming in to
save you
he becomes the villain if he rose he
becomes he becomes that same villain
right because who ends up with all the
power money and control then right
people in government yeah and right who
are the people that end up taking
advantage of everybody else once they
get that power people and when people
say yeah until one person when people
say democratic socialism but Maduro was
he was elected yeah if you say it was a
special election because Chavez died
fine so de Chavez was elected yeah if
you asked was it you were tipped a
little bit by endorsements from one Jeff
Spicoli and Bernie Sanders still pretty
sane free yes sorry
leftist you can't blame
you can't blame this on corrupt leaders
now when your system this is what the
system of socialism is what grants them
unbridled power in the first place the
fact that a socialist turns into a
dictator because you created the sole
environment where he can become an
all-powerful dictator is your fault
yes and we already did a video debunking
John Oliver's lies specifically in
Venezuela why it failed you can watch it
on the channel but let me give you kind
of a brief summary for people who
understand they try and say well it's
about the economy okay
Venezuela most oil-rich country in the
world yeah more so than Saudi Arabia a
lot of people don't know this yeah
Chavez reserves had the state run the
oil industry instead of investing it
back into the oil industry right fessing
profit for the economy to grow other
sectors they used it to pay for a ton of
socialist programs that people liked him
for a while creating a bubble that burst
when the oil market didn't do that well
so what was a road bump for the
capitalist economies was an absolute
disaster for Venezuela try so before
these protests this is what's important
to know right now you see them being run
over with tanks and shot by their
government it seems severe but before
this they were starving gift they were
digging through trash for food
yeah pretty mother says it is the only
way he getting up no no at least we have
not died of hunger
yeah his likes having to do this he says
he finds food that is edible
so socialism doesn't just kill people by
running them down with them with tanks
it starves them first yeah well in
socialism presumes that there is this
benevolent class of geniuses out there
that are able to run the economy and
take care of everybody better than
anybody else would be right history has
never shown that to be the case anyone
that gets into power and has power like
that historically has always like you
said led to being a dictator in killing
there's that's why I can't stand West
Wing every time you watch that they just
assume that everyone who happens to
another Martin Sheen yeah is it Ryan
yeah exactly that why is that the case
where does that come from you've never
seen an example of that in history why
would you think it would happen now they
didn't do it right doing it the way you
told them to do it crap I don't mean a
successful socialist country I mean nice
to hold Bernie Sanders to
onward let's just mean give us credit
fun now what we talking about important
and I don't want to be simplistic so let
me let me back this up gun rights are
necessary for a free society essential
so here you can see someone on MSNBC
suppress actual emitting that
Venezuelans are completely powerless
because they don't have gun rights you
have to understand in Venezuela gun
ownership is not something that is open
to everybody so if the military have the
guns power and as long as Nicolas Maduro
controls the military he controls the
country that would never happen to her
though
come on no whatever happy is it I know
what people are going to say that people
been saying this non-stop on social
media like what they call the reverse
Nirvana fallacy I think they call it
that and either in either rhetoric
lodging or philosophy I don't know which
is taught in college remember I learned
about this in college well the ideal
well hall a second they if they had guns
do you think it would fix the problem
here the government has tanks okay hold
on a second so let's begin the
statistics so let me ask you this do you
think it's a better scenario that
citizens are being defenselessly run
over by tanks from their government as
opposed to a civil war scenario where
they fight back so because they're
completely defenseless right now and
they're getting bazooka to high heaven
you think they should have no way to
defend themselves III don't understand
the argument and by the way it's also
incorrect with an unarmed population
material is barely hanging on to power
okay if you dump 300 million guns with a
mix he VEB through yeah they're doing
with rocks and bottles right now can you
imagine if they were armed any ideas
like well they would just nuke well no
no there's a ground war that needs to be
fought in right now they are fighting
without guns and the Second Amendment is
designed specifically this is where
people mess it when they talk about it
being hunting I know I sound like a
broken record but it's designed
specifically to prevent this kind of
government from even attempting this
sort of tyranny but that would never
happen here yeah that's the old it would
never happen here so let's just make
sure that we have no failsafe the United
States an example if you look at the
numbers we have a population of 320
something million people yeah we have
300 something million guns I think it's
over a third
oh yeah to keep my 30% of households
yeah who own guns our total military
population is just over 2 million that's
including active and reserve personnel
yeah
there's no chance of the United States
gunning down its people because they
know the citizenry is so armed it cannot
happen and if you think again you you
think that genocide is better in
Venezuela than a civil war I need to
hear your argument when you say that
guns in the hands of civilians wouldn't
help I just don't agree no no absolutely
you have to have some kind of a
protection if these people had guns
Maduro would have stopped a long time
ago knowing that they would have come
after him if he made those kinds of
decision right but led to the conditions
they're in now he would have had a check
against him even if it wasn't used just
like we have a historical precedent for
all socialist Marxist communist
governments doing this kind of a brawl
or armed pot armed populations fighting
people Switzerland
foreign invaded during world war ii and
i know some of you will say well they
had a geographical advantage on is the
mountainous regions okay but you know
what let's use another example direct
quote from Japanese military when they
were asked why they didn't invite the
United States after Pearl Harbor said
there would have been a gun behind every
blade of grass by the way Japanese very
flowery what's your Excuse Hirono
[Applause]
whatsoever this is what's so important
it's it's so pretty there's nothing
unique about Venezuela all it would be
if you could find an exception no all
big government and socialist leaders
disarm their citizens yes everything I
hope you doing in Cuba
Nazi Germany so socialism with socialism
disarmament is the rule not the
exception
yeah in every case yeah and one of the
thing I'm baffled at how people are
forgetting recent military history
Vietnam Vietnam and think about this
insurgents will always outlast an
invading always you know why because I
only been there not centralized you kid
okay wouldn't they Nukem fine they would
nuke a city there's millions more we're
not centralized all standing in one
place saying we're gonna fight you from
here right it is one of the most
impossible tests look at Afghanistan
ten years fifteen years later we're
still trying to take care of an
insurgency right right so we would and
we came as a matter of fact I'm pretty
sure we'll talk with Senator Rand Paul
after the break and he'll tell us that I
know he doesn't think we should still be
there because he's right it's unwinnable
but say something brother that was guys
that buy into good point I mean to the
contradict out a little bit when
you think you was history only started
in January 2009 what's the Vietnam right
yeah exactly yeah yeah I understand that
but man what lesson number two this one
is kind of an aside but I wanted to
include it is it we learned that Trump
is in a Russian Stute my important one
though so this is really simple Putin is
supported Maduro openly and repeatedly
but it was actually readying a plane did
you know to escape to Cuba yeah he was
out before the Russians convinced him
not to and I back in in January Trump
issued a statement officially
recognizing one other guy and by the way
it's also important to note that you
know Russia's had cozy relations with
with Cuba and if you look at Donald
Trump and Bolton then they're not only
there sanctions but their rhetoric on
Cuba yeah this just backs it up but if
you don't believe me and I don't think
you should believe you should net will
just lead to the fire don't believe we
believe your lyin eyes and believe your
lion ears here's President Trump meeting
with one other guy's wife telling her
that her husband is 100% the president
when asked about Russia by the way he
couldn't be more clear we are with then
as well as we are with your husband
review and with the people that he
represents which is a big big majority
of the country what's your next question
it couldn't be more forceful yeah Brian
I mean I'm just thinking about this now
what Trump did this didn't Cortez Omar
and like the other the three stooges
like attack him for it like why are you
getting involved
we shouldn't be intervening I said no I
think you think about all my ranting
about the Jews I'm a little confused
here I think I think you're right they
did yeah I have a legitimate question
wouldn't it so if Russia is this
socialist Marxist whatever like the
alternative to capitalist society over
here that they want to usher in wouldn't
they want Donald Trump to be a stooge of
the Russians so that it would happen
here why are they not anymore why are
they so opposed to the Russia connection
if
has helped communism spread around the
world and socialism bikes name so
confusing me right wouldn't they want
that why are they fighting against that
so much and tarring him like that cuz
you're racist come on give me credit
that I know a little bit what I'm
talking about
no no well hon give me specifics I I
relinquish my time I know you have so
minutes and 55 seconds left sir
not only the socials will not work but
the macro really works socialism is
outright evil and I've talked about this
many times that's not compassionate no
Maduro czar me they're running people
down in the streets shooting the Neth
this is where socialism always ends how
is there any question as to this being
pure evil
Venezuela again it's not an outline the
20th century socialist Marxist regimes
have killed over a hundred million
people tell that to your edgy atheist
friend who talks about all religions
being fought in the nay all all Wars
being fought in the name of religion yes
I don't understand please answer me how
is this a surprise to anyone if only we
had the literal exact comparison of a
Marxist out-of-control government
running over dissidents with tanks hmm
in the history books but is it possible
somewhere maybe he's starting to get the
picture and this is what this is not the
issue if you go to Rand Paul that
Senator Rand Paul a little bit socialism
it starts with it can only function was
an entirely powerless and entirely
defenseless society what the two are
different things when I say powerless I
mean people who are reliant on the
government for their health care reliant
on the government for their education
reliant on the government for their
welfare for their ability to live you
suck in a soul straight from somebody's
body when I talk about defenseless I'm
talking about systematic disarming and
one of course precedes the other this is
one thing to that that you can't I think
Thomas soul talked about this you can't
blame the leaders who seize control that
you've willingly given it given to them
you can at some point maybe it was
democratic but guess what at some point
it's not going to be let's not say
Bernie Sanders is a Maduro I don't think
he would be maybe not the next guy but
it could be the next guy and the next
guy and the next guy and you're too far
in because you're dependent on the
government based on these policies
because you thought you were getting it
gimme any let me tell me something else
here that I think is important to note
capitalism is not flawless no one here
is our something that free enterprise of
course has its problems but if I'm wrong
and this is the issue the idea of of
dispersing power but not being
centralized if I'm wrong and Bill Gates
and Jeff Bezos are corrupt and they
become like Maduro so you know what
thousands of people lose their jobs the
economy is going to do pretty poorly
yeah it'll be catastrophic economically
for a lot of people if you're wrong
people get starved and run over with
tanks so if you're gonna take the lesser
of two evils let me know what you pick
we have Senator Rand Paul after the
break
[Music]
let's all try some Waffen let's all try
some wall food let's all try some waffle
it's the wealth of firearms
quality firearm engineering for over a
century sleek lines butter smooth
triggers an unparalleled reliability
Walther created the first semi-automatic
pistol in 1908 and they've made the best
ever since so the next chance you have
demand loudly and proudly I'll try the
Walther let's all try some warfare
because they are
[Music]
hello there YouTube viewer I'm here with
my dungeon sex slave half-asian tattoo
here to tell you about mug [ __ ] why
you should join to support this content
what the thing was bought legit key
oh my dear half asian to do we don't use
safe words and neither should you
behind the paywall it louder with credit
calm / mud club where everything is fair
game joy where I'll drown him in a
bathtub
like you asked that how many genders
there are we don't need to define that
there can be an infinite number of
genders it's all about what you define I
could go around wearing a dress if
that's what I particularly wanted but
are you still a boy then because you
have a penis
I don't zoom is pop-locking exactly hop
lucky is it different drink it's a robot
like something it's more like is it more
yeah
it's like the robot but your hop block
it but you're just indicating joints
poppet I don't know seems to me like a
cultural blind spot for myself in myself
I'm very glad ever next guess we've had
so many requests for him to be on he's
obviously immensely popular with a lot
of younger political activists
particularly Millennials who are
conservatives his his brand of
conservatism again I would want him to
represent himself but really seems to
resonate with him you can follow him on
the Twitter at 2:00 Rand Paul in case
you don't know who it is we'll be
talking about his introduced plan called
the penny plan to balance the budget
among other the Senator Rand Paul thank
you for being here sir well thank you
but if they follow me on the Twitter
would that be on the internets it would
be yes Walmart's correct so long as it
remains Newton neutrality yeah that's
make sure where they would go to to the
Twitter yeah the Twitter and the the
youtubes and the books of faces where
that Game of Thrones girl also learns to
become an assassin I think not entirely
clear you're probably more in touch than
I am senator you seem to really have
your finger to the pulse of what's going
on online well we have discovered today
have you seen the new white Walker
calendar know it sounds horrifying in
the sense that people who would purchase
it's time for a fun well the white
Walker calendar has Senate Republicans
depicted as white walkers Oh sort of
some creative photoshopping it's
actually quite good you might want to
get your hands on no I'm not gonna lie I
don't mean this in any of the demonic
undead sense but because of the white
hair and the lighter eyes wouldn't
require to create of photoshopping to
make you
white Walker oh no but I'm on the good
side there's good and evil and I think
it just the evil it's being depicted
what so whoever made this must not have
thought I was even one oh no I'm on the
white Walker side anyways yeah you know
at a certain point when this story the
storylines get all muddled like you know
what I just want this whole thing to
fall first off before we get to the
penny plane which is incredibly
interesting I think people would love to
hear about it have you I know you've
been busy have you been following the
BART hearing this week what's what's
your take on that
just peripherally and a lot of people
have been talking about it on the floor
of the Senate you know I wasn't part of
the hearings right but yeah I've been
hearing from Lindsey Graham and others
that it seems like the other side sort
of lost it I mean maybe just went
completely bonkers you know over Bart or
yelling and screaming at him calling him
a liar and I guess from my view point of
view it sounds like that even Muller
doesn't dispute anything that Barr said
everything bars it was accurate
he just wanted more released of I guess
his narrative that he wrote about all
thing but I guess my point of view on
the whole Muller report and the whole
reveal is that if you're not indicted
for something the government shouldn't
release anything right now I'm against
the Muller report and it was same with
go for Hillary Clinton
I actually think Comey did it disservice
to all of us including the FBI when he
came forward and said oh we're not
indicted her that she really seems
guilty as hell on these three different
things right the government shouldn't do
that because think about it from your
perspective or an ordinary citizens
perspective that if the government
accused you of a terrible crime that
would make you a pariah in your whole
community but then it's that we didn't
commit it would you want the government
to say even crowds do not commit this
horrendous crime and yet we're gonna
write a 400 page narrative describing
all the things that he might have done
that we think are kind of shady but he
didn't commit the horrendous crime I
wouldn't want the government writing a
400-page report on what I've done today
before lunch I'd be incredibly
embarrassed and I don't think you would
appear on this program but that was
actually going to be my first question
because you blocked resolution calling
for the release of the Moller report and
listen you're obviously seen as an
advocate for government transparency
you're kind of seen as that that that
candidate the torchbearer if
well so for those folks not in the know
you know you explained also when you
block this this resolution also that it
was important to understand the origins
of where the investigation began so for
people who might say well I'm surprised
Senator Rand Paul blocked a threat why
don't you want the report released
explain the context see I'm an advocate
for individual liberty and so I'm an
advocate for the individual and I'm an
advocate for government being controlled
and restrained from what it can do to
individuals so I look at a prosecution
or a prosecution where they do not find
something that they can actually prove
someone who's guilty of that the
individual deserves the protection that
not the permanent there isn't an
overriding sort of only must be
transparent about something that could
destroy an individual what we didn't
actually have proof that they committed
a crime so I think in this case the
individuals rights would trump any sort
of argument for transparency now in
general should the government try to be
transparent sure sure it's always about
how big is the government what does the
government do to the individual and what
do we do to protect the individual from
a government that might grow too large
and this is what I told the president I
was with the president this weekend we
played golf and I said they've
mistreated you the intelligence agencies
have mistreated you the special
prosecutor has but my advice is that he
needs to generalize this and talk about
what would happen for example if the
government could look at all the tax
returns of everyone they didn't like a
political enemies list so Republicans
get mad they look at all the Democrats
tax returns Democrats get mad they look
at Republicans or what if we had special
prosecutors for everybody and so we
don't know that there's a crime you've
committed but we say you know what we do
is we have a person we're gonna look for
wrongdoing then that look is an
injustice and it's important that people
realize and remember that there's a
burden on the government to prove guilt
and that's a tough learn we do it
intentionally because we want to give
the any kind of degree of doubt to the
individual we want to make the
government have a bigger burden their
burdens to prove guilt right and what
why moer really screwed up in this
report is Moeller failed in the one
sense of understanding that the burning
heel comes to the government because he
says at one point
oh but we cannot exonerate the president
I think he actually uses those words
right well that's that's not his
business and it's not the business of
government to exonerate the business of
government is to overcome a hurdle and
this is burden of proof to prove
someone's guilt because if we had to
prove everyone innocent it's like oh I'm
pretty sure Stephen didn't do that and
we're not going to indict you but I
can't absolutely say that Stephens
completely innocent of all crime right
the window of that and and the
government's full force and power
it's a terrible power we have to be very
careful and I'm sad I won't ever vote
for a special prosecutor because I don't
think it's the right justice we have
grand juries we have normal prosecutors
but we don't need special prosecutors
they don't do everybody's life from the
beginning of time that's a very good
point and that leads to the innuendo of
you know Donald Trump angrily tweeting
or saying I didn't do anything and I'm
saying hold on a second is that
obstruction right it goat leads to that
one second if there's no crime how can
we now declare it to be obstruction and
it really does become a slippery slope
and I'm amazed at the media coverage of
this right and I think you're exactly
right how can you start something that
wasn't a crime and actually no one's
actually saying he did instruct anything
there's nothing he actually did that
stopped the wheels from turning the
Moller investigation went forward thirty
five million dollars worth you know I
don't know where there was actual trucks
and did people talk about ways we can
try to get the stupid Muller
investigation over I think they didn't
talk about that right but there was no
crime and it turns out it was a false
allegation so if you're falsely accused
of something and you try to get the
charges dismissed and you work hard to
make sure that whoever's trying to
accuse you the false crimes doesn't
succeed or you obstruct justice
are you actually helping and abetting
just or even it gets to the point you
know where Barr answered a question from
I think it was Kamala Harris yes it was
come on Harrison she asked a question
she said have you heads has the
president want to make sure I had get
this correct has the President or anyone
else instructed you to investigate
anybody and they're trying to act as
though that's an own I'm going plate and
the bar said uh I'm grappling with the
word anyone else it's like asking hold
on have you senator
and Paul or anyone else ever said
anything bad about anyone and then if
you say I don't think so is that
obstruction it seems like they're going
to more generalized questions if you
look at the hearing it was no longer
about legality it was about if he's a
nice guy or not
right well I think they're getting at
whether the president has asked them to
investigate the investigators once I
came up this fake dossier should they
and I think they should because they
think it's very important that we had
the head of the CIA John Brennan who
swear swore under testimony that he
never saw this dossier till January well
he had a task force for six months
looking into this it had members of the
FBI and his team you think he never saw
one of those letters from Christopher
Steele
I think he's parsing words and this is
the kind of stuff that they'll do to you
the dossier wasn't a dossier until they
put all the letters together right for
that there's 20 individual letters so I
think you read the letters and then when
they were put together in a folder and
called a dossier agent who I have not
seen the dossier abstraction okay yeah
yeah but really so much of this
originated in government government what
took a dossier that no one would believe
and to get people to believe it they
gave it to people like John McCain who
then gave it back to the government if
you guys like will join McCain gave us
this dossier but we already gave it back
to us all we need to investigate because
the senator has given us what we are had
that we gave them the beginning well
look what we found in Senator Rand
Paul's recycling bin you put it there
let's not get into details here let me
ask you this because you've obviously
been a critic of President Trump in the
past and I think you've supported I
think you've been very fair what is it
like you said you played golf with him
is is is it tense at all do you have a
good working relationship together you
know we get along pretty well we both
love the game of golf which helps he's
very competitive and so we have a good
competitive round usually when we play
and really doesn't get overly serious
but I can tell you through the round and
being around him a long time and hearing
his statements then I'm very encouraged
by some of his sentiments and his
instincts and I'm giving an example in
the State of the Union he said that
great nations don't fight perpetual Wars
I
three more none of the bushes would have
ever said that none of the establishment
Republicans would have ever said that it
takes somebody who hasn't been muddled
and drugged down by all of the
establishment neoconservative rhetoric
to say something like that but it's
exactly what I believe right nations
don't by perpetual war and in private
and in public when I talk to him he says
that he wants to be the president that
gets you know that ends some of these
wars in Afghanistan we're spending fifty
billion dollars a year there's not a
general left at the Pentagon who
actually believes that there is a
military solution Afghanistan so I don't
want to send the last kid or send one of
my family members over there to fight in
a war where every general saying there
is no military solution we can take more
village so we can have a better
negotiated settlement well if the people
over there don't want their current
government they're going to get rid of
them and frankly the current
government's full of a bunch of thieves
drug warlords they grow more poppy in
Afghanistan than they ever have even
though the US government and the
taxpayer spending eight billion dollars
trying to wipe out their poppy crop they
grow more than they've ever grown right
it's a place you could you do better
probably to burn the money if we just
put it in a big burn bin and burned it
well I actually knew a kid in high
school who spent $800 on pot but it was
California Poppy which actually is not
the same he thought he was gonna make
poppy tea and get blitzed and he was a
very dumb person never made it to
college but before I get to the penny
plan which is what I want to get to you
mentioned that so III I am curious how
does that go when you speak with the
President on Syria for example obviously
you've adamantly been calling for
withdrawal of troops from Syria do you
have those conversations you know I
think where there's agreement is that he
believes that the Iraq war was a mistake
that toppling the Iraq regime made Iran
stronger and made the Middle East
there's more unrest in the Middle East
because of the Iraq war right I think he
thinks that leaving troops in Syria that
Syria of such a mass will lead to more
problems
now his advisors are new conservatives
and people who are the stay forever
crowd they've convinced him to leave 200
but I think actually leaving two hundred
is worse than leaving 20,000 frankly
because 20,000 aren't going to be picked
off by suicide
Baumer 200 cook you know it happened at
the barracks in Beirut Ronald Reagan
decided you know this place is you know
crazy over there and we're just not
staying and he brought the troops home
from Lebanon I think Trump has great
instincts on that and even at the very
least if he put them on you know I'm not
for staying forever in Iraq also but be
better to have him on a military base in
Iraq and it would be in the middle of
that war in between the Turks
the jihadists which some on our side
call allies we armed jihadists right
probably for five years we sent arms to
people who hate us who would just soon
skin us alive who hate Israel that's who
we were sending arms to throughout that
because we thought they'd be better than
Assad I'm not positive that the people
we were arming we're any better or would
be better than Assad it seems like it's
always a struggle because obviously when
you think you're dealing with the worst
evil you ally yourself you ally yourself
with the people who you think would
would do the least amount of damage and
then you know hindsight is 20/20 okay I
do want to get to because we can talk
about this all day and I really
appreciate it but the penny plan your
plan to balance the budget for people
who don't know I know they can follow
you on twitter they can go check it out
on youtube explain it to them
we have a problem a debt 22 trillion
dollar debt every year now we're adding
about a trillion new it seems
statistically significant I'm with you
approximately we spend approximately
four trillion we bring in about three
trillion those are around in numbers but
that's about it
and so what we would like to do is
actually cut on the spending side but we
want people to realize that it actually
wouldn't be as dramatic as people make
it out to be people like oh it's too
much we can never do it so nothing ever
gets done and everybody says oh we never
could we could never cut so what I've
come up with is a plans to cut 1% so 1%
of 4 trillion is 40 billion right and
you do it every year for five years and
for the last several years if you did
one penny a year for five years of
budget balance but because we don't do
the penny plan it's actually a little
bit harder so we actually this year we
had to rename it it's confusing
marketing reminisce all the new penny
plan okay now you have to spend 98
percent of what you spent last year if
we can do it for five years but here's
the rub and it leads to
one of the big lies of Washington so
when I present this when the media
reports it they'll say that I'm cutting
ten trillion dollars and I'm telling you
it's 40 billion so how do we figure out
the difference government is increasing
about six or seven percent a year so
over the next ten years government will
go from you know it'll it'll increase
ten trillion dollars in spending so if
you free spending how much you cut it
they could say you're cutting ten
trillion I would say you're not having
any if you free spending right most
American taxpayers would say if we spend
the same amount
last year next year as we spent last
year that's not a cut is it oh no no
Washington we were going to increase by
a hundred billions that's a 100 billion
dollar cut so we have to explain to
people at home math and the media are so
biased in this that it's hard for people
to get but if we can get directly to the
people and say just cut 1% so every
everyday my office a half a dozen groups
come in with their hands out like this
can you see my hands yeah yeah these are
called the the seats they come for money
and I explained to them we don't have
any money did you see the debt clock in
the front office spinning wildly out of
control we have no money and so then I
say I tell you what I'll make a deal
with you
so your group last year got one hundred
million dollars could you live with 99
million next year well so well everybody
that would happen to everybody that gets
money from government be one percent
left almost every one of them even the
Liberals who believe that money grows on
trees
if you tell them that the country is
being weakened by this debt that
everybody would get one penny reduction
everybody we get 99 cents on the dollar
could you live with that for the next
five years that everybody does it for
the betterment of the country every one
of them actor says yes right you can't
find one liberal in Washington one
Democrat that'll vote for that the
problem is not just the Democrats no
Democrat will vote to cut any spending
they won't vote for any but over half
the Republicans are the same they won't
vote to cut any spent even so really
there's 53 Republicans there's about 10
to 15 that will vote for the penny Platt
the wrench devil will take a pass well
that was going to be my follow-up
question because of her
to talk about the twopenny plan the
penny plan of 1% or 2% I was going to
ask where do you cut it because of
course you know if anyone goes back and
watches The West Wing they make it seem
as though Republicans only want to put
cuts into health care and Medicare and
an education and then the left
they always only want to make cuts in
national defense so you're talking about
putting that 1 or 2 percent cut across
the board yeah I would do it across the
board
now obviously we'd be left up to the
spending committees but the rules
basically say it's 1 percent if you
choose to cut a hundred percent of
something and increase another category
you could but here's the reason you
probably should do it across the board
what we have is the opposite now
Democrats want to increase social
welfare spending Republicans want to
increase military spending so what
happens every year is there is
bipartisan compromise in fact the most
misreporting fact of all media the
biggest of all fake news is that there's
no compromise up here they compromise
every day that's a problem they
compromise to spend more money they
increase welfare and they increase the
military guns and butter everything goes
up but the military spending can only go
up if you give the Democrats welfare
spending so they'll vote for the
military spending and vice versa right
now the first could work the reverse
could work you could actually cut a
little bit from everything and actually
bring down spending but the opposite
compromise the bipartisan provides to
spend more money has been going on for
ever since probably FDR really and the
thing is you can find almost all
politicians at some point saying yeah
there is some wasteful government
spending there just usually attributing
it to the other side or like you said
the left often attributed to the
military and the right often attributes
it's a social welfare state so it seems
you're saying only 1520 Republicans
would vote for this so I hate to say it
but you pitched this wonderful plan that
to people watching we say well that
makes sense
and then you make us feel hopeless so
what can people do to support it and get
it get it going the petty plan where can
they go what should they do beat the
you-know-what out of your legislators
beat them over the head with the
telephone call them email them and tell
them why won't you vote for this and
then nominate somebody else you have a
primary to go out there and get better
Republicans and so I think the primaries
are the place to prompt place to play
and a place to put your effort not as
many people vote in the primary so your
vote counts more your money counts
or so I would go out there and try to
get better people to represent you and I
think the louder people are the better
the other thing is is by my having the
vote even though I know I won't win
because I know these people I'm around
them all the time I know no Democrat
will vote to cut the deficit and I know
half the Republicans won't but by
forcing them to vote it embarrasses them
and it puts them on record and maybe one
of them goes home and has a strong
primary challenger says why didn't you
vote for the penny plan so it has the
potential to actually upset the
applecart and get new people up here
here's the problem though they don't
want to let me out the vote I will only
get a vote if I force them to which is
what we're craftily very secretly and I
can't tell you all the secret tricks
we're using to force a vote but we think
we will get a vote in the next week
you're good well see that's the problem
is then you force the vote and you
radicalize young young youth into into
cutting 1% spending I don't know who you
think you are Senator Rand Paul but you
out with the white walkers all right we
do have to get going that is at Rand
Paul on the Twitter's Senator Rand Paul
one of my favorite guests I do hope that
it doesn't take this long to get you
back I really appreciate it and I do
hope that we see this vote thank you
thank you very much God bless we'll be
back to wrap this up after this
[Music]
[Music]
you have fun and we win everything they
always do bug Club in character hey
there steven crowder here with an
important safety message now I know that
Sunday is Cinco DeMayo and you're going
to enjoy your festivities and I want you
to have your fun take part in your
neighborhood contribute and of course be
sure to alert your local authorities the
number is below happy 5
[Music]
sir we're gonna take these funds for the
old town road we're gonna buy a ton of
black asphalt we're gonna take these
funds for the old town road we're gonna
yeah hey and then also fix potholes we
could take these funds for the old town
road and maybe build a brand-new stadion
tire job to fix the old town road we
mustn sure that is he even listening I'm
thinking no this is so exciting look the
roof in shining so touched by this
project I named it Joe Biden sir this is
dismaying taxpayers our pay studies show
these never create economic growth
you're saying can't nobody tell me
nothing
you can't tell em nothing can't nobody
tell me nothing
you can't tell em nothing
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the when I first learned
to swim and I wasn't confident and I
wasn't supposed to be in the water I
went in the water anyway and I would
just push off edges and grab a breath
push off the ladder go yeah that's what
I did
it's horribly dangerous by the way you
amazed it we get it and you want to be
black they've rejected you nature hasn't
been kind they haven't taken you in
that's one of their own you were telling
me about something
Thank You Senator Rand Paul by the way
next keep in mind next week there will
be a change my mind you guys saw the
teaser will be a change my mind on
Tuesday there won't be any other shows
because a tender mind takes a lot of
work and we're moving into a new studio
yes so we're moving all of the Edit Bay
green screen where we tape all this all
that's going to a new space and then the
next phase is gonna be this actual
studio moving to that space as well so
that we don't miss like two weeks of
shows yes you were just telling me
something you and too cute man you
something you were mad about yeah so
Burger King just released this idiotic
ad today okay it's a it's okay to feel
your way mmm
so a fast-food chain yeah so
cheeseburgers yeah has an ad about
depression and sadness and say a nephew
boss like it's just this like student
film show a kid writing a few boss no
it's some it's something okay they're
all Millennials yes so extra of course
you're not you're not advertising to
people going hey like it's okay to be
like happy Miller you know happy that's
all being super depressed that's
probably because they're eating the
burgers yeah this is Burger King when I
was a kid knows trying to what then they
changed him I am I the things I would
eat a double beef whopper with cheat
with cheese and I it would get on your
fingers and it stays we the whole day
just like to remind you of your bad
decisions like you're later you're you
get that night you could be eating
chicken breasts and broccoli it's like
the mimetic remember me you're like oh
damn this doesn't okay
oh no oh well I haven't seen the
commercial but uh I don't really know
that it's worth that much time then we
just wasted hey I wanted to say want to
offer a shout-out to my father-in-law
here he's a great man loved him he had a
I mean really talk to guys he had a
blood infection
we actually got sepsis and it was really
really tough seems like he's doing
better he's gone home and when I was
looking it up I was like oh man this can
be pretty severe and because I didn't
want to upset my wife and there's
nothing we can do because in another
state some things like I talked about as
men sometimes you don't lie to your wife
like oh well you know what that's that
can be that can be okay yeah but the
truth is it's really tough can cause a
lot of organ damage anyone who has a and
he doesn't even doing well but anyone
who has info on that would appreciate it
maybe you send me some because we'll
take all the help we can get
and my wife and I was pretty tough had
to comfort this this week and you know I
really just there's just people often
said all you were saying that because I
love my wife I love my father-in-law and
really fortunately love my mother-in-law
let my father loved my mother and my
father and my wife and we really we all
get along pretty well but I will say
this my wife and I have had conflicts
quite a bit and same with my
father-in-law he's a great man we've
gotten into it a few times and I think
it's important this is what I wanted to
talk about today conflict is not
inherently immoral I think this ties
into what we were talking about with
Venezuela this is why I pushed for truce
over middle ground common ground is fine
if it's founded on truth but middle
ground isn't if it's founded on a lie
it's just a polite lie we have an entire
generation of people kinda like you're
talking about with with Burger King who
believes that conflict in and of itself
is immoral or even impolite no conflict
leads to breakthrough conflict leads to
resolution that's the goal of conflict
my parents have been together 30 years
of my wife's parents have been together
I want to say 40-something her
grandparents 60 plus years before he got
Alzheimer's I used to see my parents
argue a lot as kids they worked it up
French can Italian Americans they have
nothing on French Canadians my mother is
a you know where she's of she knows what
she wants
yes she can be a pushy woman so can my
wife they worked it out though so I used
to see my parents argue and I used to
watch them work it out the alternative
to those conflicts and the subsequent
resolution is divorce and when you have
a generation of people who were raised
on that you just need to make yourself
happy you do you if you're not happy in
your marriage you need to make yourself
happy if you're not happy in your job
just find something else
life's too short you need to be happy
and how many of those people do you find
end up being
it end up being happier because but more
importantly okay how many of them end up
becoming more fulfilled those decisions
for short-term gain and this is a part
of the leftist worldview which
ironically is rooted in absolutism in
trying to be staunchly opposed to moral
absolutism one of the only absolutes as
many leftist but many progressives
believe is a conflict is wrong or that
violence is wrong but we're not even
talking about that today you know what
happens in a war scenario without
conflict genocide do you know what
happens on a campus bereft of
ideological conflict propaganda
indoctrination do you know what happens
in a marriage without conflict happy no
divorce complacency and I get at
conflict as uncomfortable as its it's
easy to sell people a worldview or a
political ideology that tells them their
discomfort is unnecessary unwarranted or
it's out of their control and it
promises to end all conflicts for them
I'm telling you right now that conflict
is unavoidable you can live your whole
life trying to be mr. nice guy mr.
milquetoast avoid discussing religion in
politics avoid standing up for anything
try to fly under the radar conflict at
some point we'll find you period and
that's why I think it's important for
everyone else to but I accept conflict
as a fact of life and rather than avoid
it I want to see more people learn
conflict resolution rather than learn
how to not fight in a marriage I want to
know one's gonna learn how to not fight
in a marriage no one's going to learn
how to be comfortable their whole life
no one's going to learn how to be happy
their whole life but you can learn to
find resolutions through the conflict do
you find yourself avoiding conflict of
hard conversations or have you learned
that it changed people's minds it's one
or the other do you avoid the conflicts
of your marriage do you let it boil over
or do you how do you learn how to meet
each other's needs compromise do you
avoid the conflict of your co-workers or
your friends by trying to move up in the
ranks that's one thing that happens a
lot right you try to move up in your job
and people get mad they don't like you
anymore I learned this when I became
when I became a boss who employed there
were some people didn't like me anymore
that happens you're that new your
workplace as a result you become
complacent here's the thing about
conflict and this is why I think it's so
scary when you're
it you don't know how it ends when
you're on that ascent you don't know
what happens on the other side of that
crest think think of riding a bike up a
hill it's hard and it sucks but you
often make up for time on the other side
that difficult initial climb and it
sucks don't get me wrong makes the rest
of the ride easier more efficient and I
don't want you to mistake this what I'm
talking about right here
Fred I don't want a mistake it was
advising you to live a caustic life or
to be one of those unbearable people
looking for a fight when they're there
needn't be one that's not what I'm
talking about but it's like we were
talking about earlier with Venezuela do
you know what the alternative is to a
civil war genocide or continued
subjugation and I see that on a
micro-level
happen to so many people people who
email us on the life advice shows that
we do for those who are mug Club members
people who spend their whole lives
avoiding conflict and then then they
wonder where they went wrong don't be
that person I want you to think about
this for a second thing is that our
conflict that maybe you've been avoiding
in your life that you've been putting
off because you know it's hard and it's
uncomfortable but it's necessary we all
have it we've all done it don't be that
person if you find yourself in conflicts
throughout your life listen you're gonna
lose some yeah that's unavoidable but if
you avoid the fight your whole life I
guarantee you that you'll find yourself
in a prison of your own making haunted
for the rest of your life by the idea of
what could have been don't be that
person don't avoid conflict because it's
uncomfortable all right I'll see you
next week but not before Thursday to
twill change my mind Tuesday
[Music]